foreign
up next we have Julie in Phoenix hey
Julie welcome to the show
Julie hello Hi how are you Hi how are
you we're doing well
yeah
yeah
for sure uh basically I have I'm not
sure so much of financial family uh it
got to the point that I literally had to
stop speaking to my mother and I'm
guessing it has to do with finances and
I just wanted to get your advice
um I I got saved at the age of 21 I was
in debt over ten thousand dollars I put
myself in bootstraps I paid it off in
one year wow and
um after that I just kind of stayed
living in New York my mother accumulated
that from about 10 to 12 000.
um they started chewing her dragging her
to court I felt I needed to do something
because she was not doing anything and
she turned to me and I paid about four
thousand dollars to file for bankruptcy
for her
and
um there was about seven eight years I'm
30 now so that was seven eight years ago
and I paid and that was all of my money
and I made her promise and promise and
promise that she will never get a credit
card again because after I paid off all
of my credit cards and debts I caught
everything I've never used a credit card
any debt again basically and you found
that you can't change people
yes and within a year or two she had
multiple credit cards again she tried to
kind of hide it from me that they were
coming in the mail sure and then maybe
five years she was right back where she
was 10 to maybe twelve thousand dollars
and they started to try to track her to
court again yeah she turned to me
basically like are you gonna take care
of it like I I didn't know what to do I
called the attorney or bankruptcy
attorney and she was like what's wrong
with your mother you can file bankruptcy
every four to three years or five years
you can only do it every 10 years
a long story short I moved to uh to
another state of Minnesota Ministry then
covert hit she moved uh to the state
with me and then after some time it's
just she was making very not smart
financial decisions
and it was just I'm starting to feel the
point I was getting suffocated
and I when I moved when I was done with
the ministry and I moved to another
state now I'm in Arizona I
um she always wants to move in with me
so basically you know I can like pay at
least half of the bills yeah so Julie we
have a heartbreak coming up hey Julie we
have a heartbreak coming up what what
give me the situation today and how Ken
and I can kind of walk you through and
give you our thoughts uh she keeps
asking me for money
um I keep trying to move in with me okay
and I I I can yeah when I was 19 she was
encouraging me to take out a student
loan to pay attention Julie
um listen this is a hard no you've gotta
you gotta put up some boundaries Rachel
she's gotta put some boundaries up with
Mom and it's a tough situation because
it's her mother yeah yeah it is for the
last two years and she would emotionally
like blackmail me she would guilt-trip
me it got to the point where she would
call and I would like
my blood pressure would go up yeah yeah
listen listen stop speaking to her Julie
listen I I I understand this is so
wildly painful and so hard
but the fact is you're you're already in
pain she's already putting you in the
situation
it's so it's not going to get any worse
if you literally say no and you put the
boundaries it's not going to get any
worse than it already is
but by keeping by giving her continued
power
to manipulate you and I'm being very
specific with that word your mother is
manipulating you and you do love her and
it is because you love her that she has
the power to manipulate you but we can
hear the pain in your voice Rachel I
mean around it's well it is and Julie
having putting up those boundaries is
really difficult and I think being very
clear with her
and saying Mom I'm not giving you any
more money and if that is the string
that keeps us together then Julie
there's a point which is the most
heartbreaking thing when a family is
destroyed but she's destroyed like I
hear it in your voice Julie that you
can't handle this anymore and so there's
going to be a really hard boundary that
you that you had say that I just we
can't have a relationship if this is how
you're gonna treat me and this is for
the good of you Julie for the good of
you in your life and that's a hard
boundary but it's a loving one for you